IS RIGHT AND WHAT IS WRONG.
>> THE PAROLE HEARING IS SET FOR
TOMORROW.
CARLEY: THE SUPREME COURT
DEALING A MAJOR BLOW TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
REINSTATING THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY AFTER TEXAS SUED OVER THE
PROGRAM’S SUSPENSION CLAIMING IT
PLACED THE BURDEN ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FORCED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO IMMIGRANTS.
TEXAS ATTORNEY GENERAL KEN
PAXTON WAS BEHIND THE LAWSUIT IN
JOINS US LIVE.
THE PROGRAM KEEPS MIGRANTS IN
MEXICO AS THEY AWAIT THESE
ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW WITH THE
INFLUX AT THE BORDER AND THE
SURGE IN COVID CASES.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT TO REMAIN IN
MEXICO WHILE THEY YOU WAIT THE
HEARING.
>> IT IS IMPORTANT, ONE OF
DONALD TRUMP’S GREATEST
SUCCESSES BECAUSE HE HAD THE
SAME PROBLEM, INSTITUTED THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE THESE IMMIGRANTS
WERE TOLD BY IMMIGRATION LAWYERS
COME TO THE UNITED STATES, CROSS
THE BORDER, TO THE BORDER AGENT
YOUR CLAIMING ASSIGNMENT AND
DISAPPEAR INTO THE COUNTRY FOR
YEARS, NEVER HAVE TO COME BACK
SO THE IDEA YOU HAVE TO STAY IN
MEXICO AND WAIT FOR ASYLUM HERE,
WHEN 14% OF THESE PEOPLE QUALIFY
IT WAS GREATLY SUCCESSFUL UNDER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND WE
HOPE REINSTATING IT WILL HELP
ALONG THE BORDER.
JILLIAN: DHS’S RESPONSE TO THE
RULING SAYS DHS HAS APPEALED
DISTRICT COURT ORDER AND WILL
CONTINUE TO VIGOROUSLY CHALLENGE
IT AS THE PROCESS CONTINUES AND
COMPLY WITH THE ORDER IN GOOD
FAITH.
HOW LONG WILL THIS PROCESS TAKE?
>> IT COULD TAKE A LONG TIME
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
LITTLE TRIAL ON THE MERITS OF
THE CASE BUT WE WON A PULMONARY
INJUNCTION IN TEXAS AND TOOK TO
THE FIFTH CIRCUIT AND WHEN YOU
DO THAT, YOU ARE LIKELY TO WIN
ON THE MERITS WHEN THEY GRANT AN
INJUNCTION SO I FEEL CONFIDENT
THEY CAN APPEAL IT AND WE CAN GO
THROUGH THE TRIAL PROCESS AND
PRETTY SURE WE WILL WIN, WE ARE
CONFIDENT WE ARE GOING FORWARD
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
JILLIAN: IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
SAFETY OF AMERICA, FOR PEOPLE TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY LEGALLY BUT
TEXAS IN PARTICULAR HOW
IMPORTANT IS IT FOR THE STATE OF
TEXAS?
>> IT IS INCREDIBLE.
I MET WITH RANCHERS A COUPLE
DAYS AGO AND THEY ARE SO FEARFUL
BECAUSE NORMALLY THEIR PROPERTY
BEING DESTROYED BUT THEY FEAR
FOR THEIR LIVES.
I MET LEADERS ON THE BORDER,
THEY DON’T KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH
COVERT OR THE IMPLICATION OF
FENTANYL WHICH IS UP BECAUSE THE
BORDER CRISIS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, SEX TRAFFICKING, WE
HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS RELATED
TO THIS AND MASSIVELY INCREASED
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND HEALTHCARE
COSTS.
IT HAS A DRAMATIC EFFECT ON OUR
STATE AND AS THEY IMPORT PEOPLE
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY WITH COVID,
THIS WILL AFFECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CITIZENS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS PEOPLE ARE MOVED
AROUND SECRETLY BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
JILLIAN: DO YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT RESPECTS THE LAW WHEN
IT COMES TO STATES RIGHTS OR IS
HE SAYING I CAN DO WHAT I WANT
AND IT DOESN’T MATTER, THE
RIGHTS OF THE STATES?
>> NO DOUBT HE LOOKS AT THE
FEDERAL LAW AS HIS CHOICE, IF
YOU WANTS TO FOLLOW WAS PASSED
BY CONGRESS, HIS JOB IS NOT TO
CHANGE THE LAW WHETHER TO FOLLOW
THE WHETHER HE LIKES THEM OR
NOT.
I HAVE TO DO THE SAME IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, HE DOESN’T DO
THAT.
HE SAID I DON’T HAVE TO FOLLOW
LAWS, THE CONSTITUTIONAL THING
DOESN’T WORK FOR
DOESN’T WORK FOR ME SO HE TELLS
PEOPLE NOT TO ENFORCE THE LAW
AND THAT IS HAPPENING ALONG THE
BORDER.
YOU CAN COMPARE WHAT DONALD
TRUMP DID TO WHERE WE ARE NOW,
NUMBERS ARE DRAMATICALLY
DIFFERENT, THE RESULTS ARE
HORRIBLE AND IT IS BECAUSE WE
HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO LITERALLY
IS OUT OF CONTROL.
>> BEFORE WE LET YOU GO,
JULY 20TH, ’40,929 BORDER
ENCOUNTERS IN JULY, THERE WERE
212,672 JUST TO PUT IT IN